jojo siwa and kylie prue are going their
separate ways kai is the absolute best i
love her so so so so much that was the
18 year old entertainer just one month
ago gushing over her girlfriend but now
e.t has learned that the couple broke up
around mid-october after less than a
year of dating because i did it
[Music]
i found the person that makes me the
happiest i have ever been an instagram
post from jojo earlier this month first
sparked speculation about her
relationship status when she wrote in
part this has been a week my brain has
never been so overwhelmed overloaded
jojo added even though this week has
been one of the hardest in my life for
so many different reasons it's also been
one of the best
[Music]
here's one of the last photos the couple
took together earlier this month posing
during a promotional appearance at
disneyland for dancing with the stars
the other night we were watching these
are the stars and she was like can we
stop watching these and i was like why
bug and she's like
because it's not you and i want to watch
you dancing jojo and kylie first met on
a cruise getaway they began dating in
january earlier this year that same
month the triple threat came out as a
member of the lgbtq plus community i am
really
really
i'm really happy and uh
now that the world gets to see this side
of my life it makes me really really
happy i've been happy in this land for a
minute now and now though that i just
gotta share that with the world it just
it's awesome jojo first opened up about
her relationship with kylie in february
she wrote next to this photo after being
my best friend for over a year january 8
2021 i got to start calling this
exceptional human my girlfriend and
since then i've been the happiest i've
ever been jojo opened up to et about
their romance in august i've had my mom
obviously my whole life who's always
been right by my side and who i love
so much literally
my rock for forever
and it's cool to have love and support
in a different way you know what i mean
like i've obviously had the love and
support from my mom for forever and
that's the only love that i need in my
life but then having this love makes it
all so much greater you know what i mean
it just adds and it's awesome meanwhile
jojo is in the middle of a
history-making season of dancing with
the stars as one half of the first
same-sex pair to compete on the show on
top of being a source of inspiration for
many while competing on the series jojo
tells et it's also been a personal
journey of learning self-love and
acceptance sometimes i don't make myself
happy and that's something that we
talked about actually this week that i
struggle with she said you have to be
selfish for once right now you have to
take a second think about you and you
have to do what you have to do right now
and i was like that's
true and i've never thought that before
and so i'm learning as i go but i'm
finding a balance of how to make sure
everybody rounds me happy i'm happy the
world is happy so it's a battle that's
really hard to win but my goal is to win
it